[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today sometimes
John folks call in and they've already
got a laundry list
prepared of a what they're not going to
do and B why it won't work right and
three what they can't do and what they
can't do and here's the thing and I said
this to John during the bre I'm just
being candid if you call in and you say
oh you know here's the thing I can't I
can't earn more um I can't move I can't
uh sacrifice this or that or that what
would happen if I just went oh oh okay
cool well sucks to be you then what if I
just you would not be okay with that you
would go well what kind of show is this
you guys are supposed to give me advice
you guys are supposed to help me move
forward but here's the deal it only
works if you believe it works if we give
you a laundry list of things hey you
could try this you could do this uh
here's what worked for me here's what
worked for John and we're giving you
real life experience it's not a theory
we didn't just pull something out of our
butt and go hey try this you know it
might work for you we're telling you
time tested uh techniques when it comes
to money when it comes to life things
that not only worked for people out
there that you might not know or have
ever heard of but we're we're people
right here in this studio who are
telling you hey uh look we sacrific we
slept on an air mattress John pulled
himself in and out of school he made
sacrifices to make it work for his
family we're telling you that and you
can either take it or you can leave it
right you lead a horse to water but you
can't make them drink but here's the
thing you came here for a drink and
we're trying to give you that and um the
belief thing it works either way right
whether you believe something works or
you believe it doesn't like that's your
choice so the things that we have for
you the resources that we have for you
you can make it true for you or you can
make it false for you you can say hey
like I believe this or I don't and
there's a big part of that like you've
got to you've got to connect to that and
you've got to stop saying I'm the
exception to the rule well and there
used to be a cultural ethos of we can do
anything yes we can go to the Moon we
can we can go liberate Europe we can go
fight this war we can do these things
and now our cultural ethos is y'all
can't you can't it's too hard too hard
someone's got to come get you you you
guys have too much pain you just you
can't and and Jade I there's too much
standing in your way I hear I'm
frustrated by that ethos of you can't
cuz I've I've just had the privilege for
20s something years sitting with people
who have scratched and clawed and
figured it out and it's amazing to watch
them and I'm frustrated by those who
say I'm not going to do that I can't do
that I can't I can't drive a Corolla yes
you can yes you can I can't I can't just
go go to work yes yes you can I just
can't drive in the morning before work
and then deliver pizzas at night I yes
you can there's always something you can
do to better your situation always I
don't care if it's just an inch forward
you keep compiling those inches and
before you know it you will have moved
steps and Bounds and miles further you
can and even if you can't move you can
you can reach out and say will you help
me absolutely will you help me will you
help me and there will be an army of
people there it's just this but you have
to receive the help John right I know
yeah it's it's a culture of
disempowerment that is so heartbreaking
to me um we have that last caller and I
just want to tell her I know you have
this vision for your life and that's
awesome and I actually think you can get
there but you're going to have to stop
saying well I can't do that and I can't
do that and I can't do that yeah because
you're canting yourself into a miserable
miserable Place yeah and and the thing
is we can all we can all look at our
lives and find reasons why it won't work
right like I could look at myself I
could be like well I I went to high
school in a small town um I'm black I'm
a female it's harder for women to get
ahead um you know we've got this debt uh
we're just musicians musicians you know
it's feast and famine you know you're
starving artist you can make all of
these assumptions about yourself and
cause them to be true it's almost like
uh it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
like you're in a moment and the moment
sucks like let's be honest like
sometimes you can be in a moment and it
does feel like the walls are closing in
on you but the more you rehearse that in
your brain and continue to say it's true
and have no vision for the future I say
it all the time words matter Berne Brown
says whatever you go looking for you're
sure to find yes yeah she says that I
say it too and I know it came from
somebody okay but it's but it's a
beautiful thing like if I go looking for
opportunity yes we're talking on on the
plane today on the way on the way back
from New York when you said you and Sam
sat down and said if this is going to
actually work we got to start business
we have to yes we got to figure it out
we're going to start a business in and
it's like okay what do we know how to do
we're musicians so let's figure this out
and but it's a matter of hey Sheila when
we're doing it I'm going to have to
start adjuncting classes and I'm going
to have to become a professor on top of
my Dena students roles and I'm also
going to take this because we got to get
out of this mess and she's like I'm
going to lose you and I was like you're
going to lose me either way at least
this is our path loss right yes and you
grind and you grind and you grind and
you grind then the Sun comes out it does
and but what you said John is really
important I don't think people take
enough time to look forward and dream
people don't take enough time to go
they're in the moment and they see where
they're at right now and it's like uh
this is just this is me this is my life
this is how it is and I'm like no let's
take a moment and let's zoom out for a
moment in 10 years and 15 years where
would you like to be taking that time
some taking time to just stare out of a
window and think you know what would it
be like if what would happen if I had
that conversation with my spouse what
would happen if we paid off both of our
vehicles like what would that feel like
taking the time and I challenge anybody
today take some time and dream think
about how your life could be better
write down a couple of ways write and
then write down what must be true
because let me tell you something uh
John with Sam and you know for anybody
listening for the first time real quick
40 $460,000 of debt coming into our
marriage from student loans and cars and
everything else and um I knew I wanted
not early on did I know I wanted a
family but a little further in I'm like
man I want a family this is never going
to happen you know like I want to be I
had this dream of like I want to be the
type of mom who can you know go to the
field trips and be there to pick their
kid up and you know I I just had this
very clear vision and I was so so so so
unbelievably far from that and it broke
my heart and I remember saying to my
husband I'm like I can't like I can't
bring kids into this like we've got to
clean up this mess we will be bringing
them into such a mess and there was
other things going on as well too and I
remember sitting down and just being
like okay what's got to be true for
anything that we want in life to happen
because this right here it ain't it and
this is not working and we're so worth
more than this and that's a hard
conversation but once you have it it's
like okay there's the North Star let's
start reversing reverse engineering this
thing backwards what's got to happen
first and then honestly enough people
don't sit down with pen and paper and
literally write down what has to happen
A1
first and what if if you don't have a
map it's really hard to what's that
what's that old saying if you don't have
a map um you don't know where you're
going You're sure to you're sure to get
there right you just Meander around yeah
if you a if you aim at nothing you hit
it every time that's right so yeah I if
you hear I say anything folks who still
listening to this you can you can when
you think you can and it's it's 2 2 a.m.
and you're exhausted and you just looked
at your credit card
balance and you're in bed with somebody
that said I do and yall are so far apart
from each other and your kids don't want
to be around you and you think I'm out
you can and it's a little bitty step and
sometimes it's reaching out and saying I
don't know what to do next will you help
me please go make that call make that
stop and then go Get It Go Get It Go do
it look we are normal people all of us
are out here scratching and clawing if
John can do it if I can do it I know it
sounds cliche but you can surely do it
you can tell me you won't do it but do
not ever tell me you can't you can do
this